ah
the talk of Peace in Yemen doesn't drown
out the cries of the war victims
hot tubs still a teenager but he's lost
both his hands and his sight and all
hope for a better future now
his body is peppered with shrapnel
wounds many still lodged in his chest
he doesn't seem aware of how severe his
injuries are and he won't be able to get
the specialist help he so urgently needs
inside Yemen
his father appeals to us to get his son
medical help he needs to go out of Yemen
he tells us he's a human there are lots
like him but look how he's suffering
they can't make artificial limbs quickly
enough to cope with a growing number of
amputees who need them now but creating
prosthetic legs are easy in comparison
to electronic hands which are very
expensive so they mostly do cosmetic
arms
this Olive for Cosmetics
yeah yeah no that doesn't move not
functional at all it doesn't do anything
yeah it doesn't do anything
many of the amputees are children
there's a whole generation like Abdullah
growing up maimed and mutilated by this
long wall
most of abdullah's 10 years have been
spent living in this war zone he still
has Ambitions to be a footballer and is
a Taekwondo enthusiast
or Hayden punch
wow
but his life
lives to be tough and anti-explosive
teams know he won't be the last to
suffer
sad and
I help my family and friends Abdullah
asks
Hayne
you can tell them if they see anything
suspicious do not touch it do not touch
anything
lost her leg during what was meant to be
an agreed truce between the fighting
groups the 13 year old has learned how
wartime agreements on no agreements at
all in Yemen
she shows us on her good leg how doctors
had to cut more and more of her wounded
limb to Stave off infection which still
hasn't healed seven months after the
explosion
her family's traumatized about the day
she got blown up by a landmine left in
the street
Anaya's since dropped out of school and
says she's no friends now either but she
still has dreams to get Justice for war
crimes
my dream is to be a lawyer she tells us
I was thinking I'd learn English and I
want to study to be a lawyer so I can
fight and defend those who need it
but first she's got her own fight on her
hands to heal and every five days she
comes here to get her wound cleaned
it's a constant tussle between nurse and
patient
he says
tell me what to do she screams
don't do that he says he's worried about
more infection
it hurts it hurts Anaya sobs it's
acutely painful and she's had seven
months of this pain
it's turned into a regular battle of
wills
they are the best of friends
few believe she'll be the last of
Yemen's War wounded or it's really
nearing an end
[Music]
we're still in the middle of the war
not no peace is coming
it's depressing yeah or depressed here
everybody's depressed
there's still much insecurity here
despite a recent lull in fighting
Nationwide
the Hall of Taz seems like it's one big
Minefield sometimes with civilians
living right in the middle of it all
there is a small yemeni team tasked with
clearing that their International
funding's been slashed as AIDS diverted
to conflicts like Ukraine often they
can't even afford the paint to show a
paths being checked
Halo trust which gets some British funds
is now inside the city
and one of its priorities is warning
Children of the dangers of unexploded
Ordnance many of the homes here are
incubating explosives which have yet to
detonate and the Halo trust will assess
the risks and aimed to remove what they
can starting in the next few weeks there
is a constant threat in this particular
neighborhood of items being fired from
that front line
um
I believe yesterday was the latest
incident that was a martyr which was
fired slightly further down in tawa this
war has torn apart lives and torn off
Limbs and the options are very limited
for survivors like 10 year old NADA and
her older sister
nadders considered lucky because she has
an artificial hand which she struggles
to put on to show off to us
when she finally manages it it's quickly
apparent it is more of a hindrance to
her
when I push my arm inside it feels
painful she says when my bone touches
the artificial bit
it's less than six months since her arm
was blown off and her new artificial
limb has already broken and utterly
useless
Nadia tells us she wanted to be a doctor
but she doesn't think she'll be able to
now with just one hand so she's aiming
to study to be a mind clearer
I don't want others to be affected like
I have and to go through what happened
to me she says that's why I tell my
siblings I'm going to be a mind
clearance woman
and not one of us who hears her doubts
she'll do exactly that Alex Crawford Sky
News and Taz City Yemen